[Music]
foreign
you are watching The Press preview a
first look at what's on the front pages
as they arrive it's time to see what's
making the headlines with the guardian
columnist Zoe Williams and the former
conservative MP who's now chief
executive of the charity business in the
community Mary McLeod they'll be with us
from now until just before midnight so
let's see what's on some of those front
pages for you now
with the headline meltdown the mail
covers both the impending strikes at
Gatwick Airport and the sweltering
temperatures in Europe
the star refers to Holiday makers
traveling to the continent in the
extreme heat as blowtorch Brits
the express hears that just stop oil
could stage major demonstrations at rush
hour in London on Monday
the eye has an exclusive report on what
it calls the toxic levels of lead in
school drinking water
the mirror carries a poll suggesting the
majority of those surveyed want to see
the BBC news reader Hugh Edwards back on
television
according to the times the government
could scrap inheritance tax in a bid to
win more votes at the next election
the telegraph has seen a
government-backed guidance that will be
given to parents of children identifying
as transgender
the guardian says there's massive demand
for a new gaming addiction Clinic here
in the UK
and the financial times has a story
about how American banks are
capitalizing on interest rate increases
and reminded that by scanning the QR
code you'll see on screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's newspapers while you
watch us and we are joined tonight by
Zoe Williams and Mary McLeod welcome to
both of you let's start with the star
not something we um often do I have to
say and their headline there blowtorch
Brits um talking about
um British holiday makers suffering in
the heat Zoe
it's really interesting because
everybody always talks as though British
people would distract most with the heat
which is reasonable because we have
least of it but the truth is
you know British people are incredibly
robust when it comes to being too hot
and then and there's an absolute years
of evidence that will stay in the sun
way longer than any other European
nation so I think it's it's sort of
self-parody this headline it's sort of
we are ridiculous everybody else is
staying indoors we will still be on the
beaches when it's way too hot the
subtext of course is that it's way too
hot because there's an absolute heat
wave in Europe and this is dovetailing
with the climate change stories of last
week that seven of the hottest days on
record happened in one week so you know
they're kind of tabloid did
determination to stay positive and jolly
in the face of Trends which are you know
leading inexorably to the the least good
scenario that scientists have been
predicting for some time
it is
quite extraordinary
yes it does seem as if they are sort of
um making light of um what you describe
obviously and it is a very serious story
and Mary there they're saying that uh
Brits are cramming the beaches and
defying the warnings that temperatures
could hit 49
um and and getting burnt to a crisp in
the process
yeah and that sort of heat is horrendous
I mean I've once been in Egypt in just
about 45 degree heat and you couldn't
move and the and so yeah I can well
imagine probably Brits are the the worst
at doing this and staying out no matter
how hot it is but
um I mean I just I'm someone who burns
really easily I'm just so so white
skinned and therefore it's you know the
whole thread of melanoma cancer and and
things that just aren't you know people
should be covering up they should be
putting SPF
um and the sorry to be so serious about
it but it really is you know it
threatens life and and so if people can
still enjoy it
um and just be sensible with it and as
everything in a balanced way isn't it
where it's yeah cover up
put sunscreen on and enjoy it and have
fun but just be reasonable drink lots of
water be hydrated and it's really the
the way to go and and just enjoy it so
sometimes in the shade and you can still
have fun it doesn't need to be on the
beach for so long and but but take a
break but I'm not surprised at this
headline we I think we all know it does
happen yeah so we'll let that famous um
phrase only Mad Dogs and Englishmen go
out in the midday Sun seem to be living
living up to that but you can have just
as much fun in the shade I often do
um let's move on to the the mail and
there they're combining the stories of
the the Heat Wave and also the impending
strikes at um Gatwick which is also
going to cause people lots of problems
over the the summer months Zoe
this sort of bugs me about the Daily
Mail I have to say and I don't mean this
in a partisan way obviously I'm from a
paper of a different political
persuasion but this is a completely
neutral observation they do periodically
roll together a number of negative
events which completely
completely free them from having any
editorial stance on those events right
so the Daily Mail is is typically very
very anti-strikes refuses to even engage
with the idea that strikes might have a
legitimate basis in pain conditions
they're very very skeptical about
climate change they tend to refuse to
even engage with the idea that the
climate may be changing as a result of
human activity
um but they they won't obviously when
those things come to crisis they have to
notice because they're still a newspaper
so they write these kind of flappy
headlines oh chaos is going to be way
too hot Gatwick is going to be disrupted
even if you escape the Gatwick
disruption on the way out you you you're
not going to escape it on the way back
in this is all in chaos but because they
absolutely refute the kind of systemic
problems underneath those situations it
just sounds like they sound like chicken
licking you know they sound like they're
just running around
announcing disaster
um and that does annoy me I have to
admit
married to you
um see anything in in that analysis that
that you agree with but the the male
aren't engaging in in the reasons uh
behind the strike and are just uh you
know doom doom saying
well it's whether you look at the angle
from heat or strikes
um there's important things underneath
it isn't it and and with strikes it's
about you know are people getting paid
uh Fair salary what are the wages and
that they're on what are the conditions
that they get and the benefits that they
get and and you know it's important
employers look at what they're doing and
and make sure that the best possible
place to work so
um and then it's what naturally can be
afforded in whichever sort of Industry
you're in but you want to treat all your
staff fairly that should be the the
going in position and but when it's
putting it alongside also I mean with
the the heat aspect and sort of climate
change and Zoe mentioned I mean it's
literally you know yeah I mean the
temperatures across
um the whole world are I mean it's a
whole direct consequence of climate
change what else is it and so it's
really important that that everyone
engages with that and comes up with
really innovative ways to address it and
and we do that on a daily basis and I do
with businesses all the time and helping
them Reach Net Zero and earlier and
trying to get them to get 220 40 and 10
years earlier
um and before that's 10 years for the
government goal but but yeah it's a it's
important that we all engage in in this
debate because it's not going to be done
by one person doing something we all
collectively and individually need to do
so much to to drive better outcomes and
get us to that sort of just transition
and and get um climate action happening
uh Zoe the times going into a bit more
um depth and detail about
um the strikes and they they speak to to
the unions and we've got the unite Union
being quoted as saying inevitably um
disruption will be caused two flights
but there it's a more um in-depth piece
I feel like the times is sort of I mean
I know this would be a ridiculous thing
for a newspaper to try and do but I feel
like they're trying to prepare the
ground for some peace to be reached
before that day of the 29th of July
um you know the the the the dates that
are proposed for these strikes are
absolutely Peak going away for some
holidays and if you think about how that
juxtaposes against the cost of living
crisis if you had your holiday that you
probably could only just afford
like completely ruined by airport chaos
that would be socially quite disruptive
um and I feel like I mean I might be
wrong but I think a year ago the times
wouldn't have even engaged with the
Union point of view I feel like they're
engaging with the Union point of view in
order to broker some kind of
communication between the unions and the
and the bosses because
it's it you know it would be a crying
shame if those strikes went ahead the
summer was ruined for tens even hundreds
of thousands of people and they came to
an agreement later anyway that would be
a real crying shame the times are
reporting that talks overpayer due to
resume next week and they've got this
rather um helpful q a section about um
obviously lots of people who'd be
wondering if their their summer holidays
will be ruined and how exactly they'll
be affected Mary
and I'm away next week
um I'm going from Heathrow but there's
often a repercussion on some of these
things and and certainly if there's a
the whether it's different countries in
Europe that are are more effective by
this and and I really hope Gatwick
therefore can resolve it because it ends
up being innocent people families often
young ones as well and having to either
get really disappointed from our
holidays or be having to wait long time
and hours in in an airport which is in
conducive to to Family Life frankly so I
really hope they can resolve this this
is supposed to be a positive time of
year for families can get together
friends and you know and just get away
and and have some proper family time and
so it's a it's a real shame that this is
happening right now and I guess it's why
they're doing it just right at those
sort of summer holidays that are
important so yes if they can sit down
and and go through and and really sort
something out would be a you know a huge
incentive to to people stop worrying
about it as well because they're just
going to worry about it over the next
um few weeks before as they approach
their summer holidays and and are
worried about the disruption that that
might happen because of this so we've
just got about a minute and talk about
this uh just stop oil story in front of
the express uh reportedly planning
massive protest on Monday to to paralyze
London
when I was quite interested in the
Express's juxtaposition right because
they're the only paper that didn't lead
on the weather chaos so you've got
basically the whole Suite of the British
and international media leading on a
heat wave which is making our normal way
of life completely untenable you know
you can't go on holiday you can't go to
the Acropolis you can't have a train
strike in Italy because people are
fainting on the platforms you you know
all the things we used to take for
granted about living normally are being
capsized by the temperatures on Mainland
Europe and then the express goes proper
hysterical about the disruption of just
stop oil and I think they've misread the
mood I think there are times on a kind
of gray September day when they might be
able to get away with railing against
climate change activists but when you
can see the effects all around you and
the express is going put just stop oil
in prison you know use your new powers
they look ridiculous